-Our first guests tonight are
two talented actors you know
for their work
in movies like "Aquaman"
and "The Guardians
of the Galaxy."
They both star
in season two of "See,"
which is streaming now
on Apple TV+
with new episodes every Friday.
Let's take a look.
-Everyone close to you
always ends up suffering.
Now it's your turn.
-Leave this place, Edo.
Please.
It is over.
-No, it's not over.
Not while you're
still breathing.
-Please welcome to the show
Jason Mamo-- Momoa
and Dave Bautista. Gentlemen.
[ Laughter ]
Ma-Ma-Ma-Ma-Ma!
How are you, fellas?
[ Laughter ]
-Better watch your ass,
Seth Meyers.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah, you're safely in London.
I have nothing to worry about.
[ Laughter ]
Thank you for staying up late,
Jason.
I know you're in London,
and I do appreciate you making
the time for us this evening.
I also heard -- not to make
things boring for people
who don't know what
we're talking about,
that you're also a West Ham fan.
-I am. Yes, we are. We do.
I didn't know
you're a West Ham fan.
-I am.
I have been for like 20 years.
How did that happen?
Oh, my God, look at that.
You got an actual tattoo?
How did you become
a West Ham fan?
-Oh, just 'cause we're family
and that's kind of what you --
the first place that you live
when you kind of come to London.
You got to claim it, so that's
what it ended up being.
-Well done. This is --
-I didn't know you were.
-I was, like, doing --
I was in London 20 years ago,
and I decided that I was
going to pick one team
and go see a game and it was
West Ham and there you go.
-There you go.
-One day we'll go
to a game together.
-Our Hammers.
-So this is very exciting.
This is the second season
of the show.
Dave, you joined the cast.
You're playing Jason's
younger brother
in a future where people
have lost the ability to see.
How did you get involved?
Did you know about the show
before you came onboard?
-Yeah, I actually --
I was a fan of the show
before I even was contacted
about playing Jay's brother.
The funny thing, you know, that
sticks out when you say that
is I'm like 10 years,
maybe more, older than Jay.
The first thing they said was,
"We want you to play
his younger brother."
And I was like,
"How's that going to work?"
[ Laughs ]
So they aged Jay up a lot
and tried to young me down.
I don't know if it worked,
but, you know, maybe we're --
I'm a year younger, but --
[ Laughter ]
Obviously older.
But, yeah, I wanted to work with
Jay for years.
I actually had reached out to
him like maybe a year and a half
before on Instagram.
I DM'd -- I slipped into his --
creeped into his DMs to say --
anyway --
just 'cause I was a fan,
I wanted to work with the dude
so bad.
So, anyway, yeah,
he contacted me
about the part and I signed up.
-Where did you guys first meet?
-Comic-Con.
-Yeah. Yeah.
-Yeah, yeah, yeah.
-Yeah.
-Yeah. We both geeked out
on each other at Comic-Con.
-[ Laughs ] Yeah.
-Were other people
there to see it?
Because I imagine if you were
just, you know, a civilian
at Comic-Con and you watched
the two of you guys meet,
that would be well worth
the price of admission.
-Absolutely.
-I don't know. I don't know.
There wasn't
a whole lot of people.
It was kind of
a behind-the-curtain thing,
but there was a few people
around, for sure.
-You also worked together
on "Dune."
And I've seen stills
from "Dune."
And it looks incredibly hot
and uncomfortable.
And then "See" looks incredibly
cold and uncomfortable.
Is this true or is this
just special effects?
-It's absolutely true.
[ Laughter ]
"See" was in Toronto in
the winter, which is brutal.
And we both pretty much had --
I mean, I know I barely
have any clothes on.
-[ Laughs ]
-But I like the cold.
Dave I think --
Dave, you like the heat, right?
-I like the heat, yeah.
Yeah, we're opposite.
I didn't suffer
on "Dune" at all.
I kind of loved it.
But on "See," I had
layers and layers and layers,
and I was still freezing.
But I don't have a full head of
hair to keep my head warm.
I had to have blankets over
my head trying to keep me warm.
But I just don't like the cold.
Don't like it at all.
Me and the cold don't get along.
-I'm very surprised to hear that
you like the cold, Jason.
You struck me as also
a warm-weather guy.
And I believe that you guys both
have history as lifeguards.
-I mean, I was raised
in Iowa, Seth.
So, I mean, I had, like,
really horrible winters
and really horrible summers
in the Midwest, so --
But I don't know.
I just like the cold.
But I didn't know, Bautista,
you were a lifeguard?
-I just found out yesterday
that you were.
Yeah, I was a lifeguard.
I lifeguarded from the time
I was like 16 till I was 24.
It was just, like,
the easiest summer gig ever.
And I would just refuse
to give it up.
So I was like the guy
who's still lifeguarding
who was way too old
to be lifeguarding.
[ Laughs ]
-I get it -- my dad, I mean,
he put me in junior lifeguards,
and so we kind of learned
how to --
that way, you just learn
how to be in the ocean.
And so all my family
were true lifeguards.
My great uncle is
Buffalo Keaulana.
He saved many, many, many lives.
So it was kind of an honor
where you come from in Hawaii.
I wasn't sitting by a pool.
Not that there's anything wrong
with that.
-I was sitting by the pool, man.
[ Laughter ]
-It's a big-ass wave, Seth.
You know what I'm saying?
-Biggest lifeguards to the worst
neighborhood pools, man.
Just have all these bad kids
just running around.
-In the 8 to 10 years
that you were a lifeguard, Dave,
did you have to do
any thrilling rescues?
-No. I mean, the water,
you know,
it only really went up
to like six feet.
It was like six feet deep.
I was like, "Don't make me jump
in," and I was still --
But, no, never --
like, I never saved a life.
It never came to that,
but I was always just kind of
hanging around, yelling at kids.
-Yeah, I would feel like you
probably wouldn't run too fast
on a pool if Dave Bautista
was in the chair.
-No.
-Yeah.
-The guy I used to work with,
he was a childhood buddy
of mine, too.
And he was a football player
who was just as big as I was.
They, literally -- They'd send
us out to, like,
the worst neighborhoods
to lifeguard the pools
'cause the kids were
just rowdy as hell.
We'd just yell at them all day.
We'd just yell at them.
And that's typically
what it took.
-There you go.